what kind of pets do I have two dogs and
two cats okay okay oh I have one dog
three cats and they were all rescues
they were all one cat literally broke
into our house and just like not kidding
the first one just we found our cat on
the second floor in my wife's closet and
was like not going this red looks real
nice going he'd like that then since
then we have other cats because the kids
want to catch so tell me about your your
animals are you really I'm a big animal
lover but I moved recently and one of my
cats who was always really mild-mannered
decided to start screaming for like six
weeks all night and kept me up all night
and I didn't know what to do when I
researched on the internet I closed
doors I opened doors I left food out I
took food away and finally as a last
resort I had a friend who'd used a pet
psychic and I decided that I am really
open to all that stuff and I thought you
know what it's worth a shot to talk to
this pet psychic it worked for my friend
and I want to see like what her advice
would be so she channeled I talked to
her on the phone she didn't know
anything about the cats was to that no
house call just to throw house call just
a phone call right and she told me that
he hated his name and he wanted a new
name what was the dog's name it was a
cat my cat's name was Addison right who
didn't like it he was like Addison he
just didn't like the way it sounded and
he wanted he he'd like to sing
apparently that's why he was screaming
and meowing all night and he told us
that he wanted his name to be Figaro
sake for short if we so chose to call
him fig so we we listened and I'm
telling you I know it sounds absolutely
bonkers but it shifted his like
everything in the house changed like the
order the natural order of the house
shifted and he was happier he's like
he's more like I don't know he's like
more vivacious than like frisky and like
no
I'm telling you what happened this woman
gave you that advice and then that night
switched cats up I want to talk to this
boy did the pet psychic just talked to
you did you put the cat on the phone she
just told me he was unhappy with his
name and she was right
Wow loves his name okay I mean you can't
argue this man yes
telling you this can you hear her
stifling laughter to change her dog's
name from his name from Albert - Albert
oh yeah totally different dog yeah she's
psychic in one area it's probably the
name yeah that'll be ten yeah yeah guess
what I hated my name is a kid no one did
nothing about
really Coenen isn't that like a
barbarians name you'll take it and like
it
anyway I channeled my dad it's a sec
we're good
you